it's also about our future well mr.
drainie a I thank you for giving me hope
the work that your organization is doing
is quite commendable and in your words
I'm just exciting to see that part we
say together we are in making his we are
not making history we're actually making
the future and with that please help me
to get some questions to Ally the
microphone is right there in the center
in and if you do not mind standing up I
apologize for that but you will be on
c-span and I'll be the exciting part and
one at a time please not too many
listeners or base ability hi I actually
had this argument with a friend two
weeks ago about who like whether or not
immigrants pose a cultural threat to
America and I really struggled as
someone who doesn't really interact with
immigrants as much as I probably should
someone who mostly interacts with other
white people how to talk to my white
friends about that cultural fear and I
was wondering if you had any specific
advice mm-hmm
what do you think the fear comes from
don't worry I'm not going to ask
everybody so I think it's partly a fear
of like difference but also like when I
had this conversation with his friend I
think it's partly a fear of like scarce
resources which is weird to me because
the point that I brought up is like
immigration was okay when our parent or
when our great grandparents and
ancestors did it like but it was but
it's not okay now and she was like what
was fine for the country then and I was
like it wasn't fine for the Native
Americans so I don't know it was that's
really helpful because I think the you
know the debate these days is not as
sphere that's based on terrorism but
it's also fear based on a real economic
anxiety that is you know terrifying to
people in the book I reference a study
from last summer that was a Gallup
survey it was an analysis of the Gallup
survey
and the Gallup survey is a sample of
3040 thousand people so it's a big big
sample and what they found was that one
of the primary reasons that folks voted
for President Trump was that they did
not feel their kids would do better than
them and you know the majority of folks
who who made that decision also lives in
culturally isolated communities so you
know I think that you know for us as an
organization and is that if we don't you
know acknowledge that economic anxiety
then we make a really really big mistake
and you never you never change anybody's
mind if you don't or heart if you don't
it admit that or understand try to
understand it I think one of the things
that we have to do then is really try to
find the messengers who are who've been
the United States for generations who
have seen their job expand because of
the immigrant that they're working with
and we've tried to really and because I
think as a movement we've done a great
job of telling the story about you know
the immigrant engineer the immigrant CEO
but that doesn't really resonate in this
day and age and maybe it never did with
the American worker and their family who
were just terribly worried about their
own livelihood or even more importantly
their child's livelihood so for us we
are always trying to engage the folks
who have been here their families have
been here who have either developed the
relationships with the immigrant
community who have you know been a part
of those conversations I was in the I
was in Idaho a few weeks back and you
know did meetings with Idaho dairyman
who were you know terribly happy that
president we have a trump administration
but equally angry that you know the
Latino you know dairyman who more or
less take care of their half a million
cows every day they're terrified to go
to work whether they're documented or
not so I just I think we're at a tipping
point right now as a society where folks
who are conservative or liberal who have
been here for generations and are you
know have no relationship to their their
immigrant history are beginning to ask
the question
okay how do I care for and value the
immigrant that I know or even they've
heard that I don't know
let's see who's gonna get to the
microphone first and George you talk
very much thank you you know I think the
issue of fear is a legitimate issue but
sometimes I think we let people off the
hook when we talk about fear because
there's this other issue of racism and
and if you look at the history of
immigrants coming to this country over
200 years there was it was a portion of
that was fear but a portion was just
outright racism but these people don't
belong here because they're different
because they're inferior whatever it is
and that's been built in to the ideology
of this country for forever and I'm just
wondering as you went out into the
country and you talked and if people
talked about fear did you raise the
issue of racism are you really afraid or
you just don't want these people to be
here simply because they're so different
because they will threaten our culture
in the way that we are and the way that
we think a lot up and get this question
you know is it is this racism and I
think that this is an issue that is
hamstrung you know blocked is such a
fire a hot point because there's a
combination of race and class it's not
one or the other I think it's both and
when you put those two issues of race in
class together
it is a very very difficult not to
unravel there's a little bit that I
wrote in the book and you know let me
let me put it this way you know there
are 15 to 20 percent of Americans who
were never gonna change
on this issue and they are you know they
look at this through purely erases a
racial racist prism and you know we're
not going to move them but there are
another I would say 20 percent if not
more of Americans who are going to have
fears that are based on somebody's look
or accent or where they're from who are
not racist they're just saying okay how
do I figure this out and I feel like you
know so if I sit here and say you know
the 40 50 % of Americans who voted for
Donald Trump are a racist I'm wrong I
think that there are people who are
grappling with this and this is what
we've we've
through the book as we found everyday is
that there are people who are grappling
these questions in a really honest way
but their churches are changing so I
wrote about churches in Houston in South
Carolina I went when I was in Utah I
went to a General Conference in Utah and
they were over the last five ten years
these religious bodies have changed so
dramatically and and therefore you know
the pastor is able to engage their
values framework their faith as a way
for folks to say okay we can work
through these racial anxieties these
economic anxieties to actually get to a
place where the church is seen as a
diverse community and therefore the
community the city the state the nation
is a diverse community so that's you
know one of those questions of race come
up yes we're gonna lose some people but
I think there are a lot more people out
there who are politically and socially
conservative where we just have to work
to find
okay what's the values framework that
makes that resonates most deeply with
them okay I have a question and I've
been teaching for 17 years this year I
saw more vitriol and you know I guess
just attitude for my students regarding
the election and of course one of the
first things I did was look at the the I
guess the voting map and even within the
red states wherever you saw either a
major university or like a giant city
you saw blue and so one of the
discussions I saw online was well if
you're a teacher then perhaps instead of
just being angry that the election
didn't go your way if you were blue then
perhaps you should go to a red rural
area to kind of fight the battle that
way because it's not I guess we are
diverse but maybe the problem is that
red areas and especially rural areas
they don't really see what's going on in
these cities and the major cities and so
I'd like to know your opinion on that so
just about everybody that I interviewed
and again for us as let me take a hot
second describe the national immigration
forum if that's helpful because I've
referenced it a few times so the
organization they run is the national
immigration forum or based in Washington
DC our mission is to advocate for the
value of immigrants and immigration to
the nation and we do this in a way where
our goal is really to bring new voices
into the debate so we work in parallel
to with the traditional immigrant rights
community but you know 80 90 percent of
our organizational resources are spent
engaging faith law enforcement and
business leaders across the country and
one of the coalition's that we've built
and really there goes the neighborhood
is about as a story about this coalition
is bibles badges and business for
immigration reform and the theory is
that if you hold a Bible you wear a
badge or you own a business you want to
come and cents solution to the
immigration system and to get your your
address your question nearly everybody
that I interviewed knew that all of our
work takes place outside of cities we're
not worried about cities we're worried
about how our community rural and
suburban communities engaging this
cultural change and I think there are
two if not three really important
institutions where those changes take
place and can be grappled with in a very
constructive way number one of schools
so this when I wrote about South
Carolina I spent some time in
Spartanburg South Carolina which is
Upstate South Carolina city of about 50
60 thousand people so it's a you know
relatively small city but the school
principal that I interviewed and the
folks that I talked to the school they
were doing some incredible things in the
Hispanic community the white community
has come to seeing the schools even not
just for children but for adults as a
place where they they can build their
skills but be their relationships built
and then the other institution that I
think and I've said this already that I
think is incredibly important in
suburban and rural communities our faith
is faith institutions that's where you
see these you know these changes taking
place you know the way I put it in the
book is that they're big enough to try
something but not small enough where you
know it doesn't matter so it and I guess
one thing I would say is in you framed
it as you know taking the battle to
those areas I don't think it's about a
battle I think if we if we approach this
as you know fight a fight I'm not sure
we're solving any problems in the long
term we have time for one more question
hi I'm wondering if you have considered
fake news and how how can these
grassroots coalition's really confront
the the money and the lies and the
propaganda that our nation is pounded
with every minute of every day and how
the political organizations and I
believe both political organizations
have taken it up and how do you know
what is true and what is not and why
shouldn't all of us be scared out of our
minds I don't want to be I don't want to
live scared I think that so for us as an
organization and our well and what I
wrote about it's about finding the
leaders within communities who are
trusted so you know me going to Beaumont
Texas to talk about immigrants and
immigration I'm going to make absolutely
zero impact but finding the pastor the
police chief or the business owner in
Beaumont that person is going to be
trusted by a circle their circle their
network so I think the way that we get
around you know fake news and yes fake
news comes from both sides you know both
sides spin their facts to their their
ultimate political goal is to get beyond
the headlines get beyond you know the
the dystopian talking points and create
the whether it's the spaces on Facebook
the spaces on within institutions where
these conversations can happen and then
draw on your elected official draw on
your newspaper so that they are
reporting on and understanding that this
isn't just about the headline of the
moment that's being blared by one
political party or another and it's you
know
in 2010 or even in 2013 when there was a
second term of the Obama administration
you know I thought we're we're in the
free and clear but we've got a lot more
work to do
and I but I also think that you know the
the the polarization of the moment is an
incredible opportunity as scary as it is
there's a credible opportunity because
across the country people of all
political stripes are looking for a
different way to have this conversation
and what I loved about writing the book
is that we're able to capture some of
those perspectives well I certainly hope
that in a few years hopefully sooner
rather than later you will be coming
back with a second book perhaps you will
say that neighborhood just grew a or
something like that but I I do agree
with in the difficult topic you do leave
us with hope a I do encourage you to
visit the Barnes & Noble tent and
purchase your book and get it signed and
ask a few more questions I really
appreciate your questions that you
provided to the author but especially
Ally thank you for being in San Antonio
you're always welcome and don't forget
to take as many Fiesta paints as
possible before but I also want to thank
Rob he's just an amazing friend and her
amazing partner just a great moderator
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
next up from the san antonio book
festival alexandra Zapruder
granddaughter of abraham zapruder the
man responsible for the film showing the
assassination of president kennedy
describes the history behind the film
and her family good afternoon
when I started so everybody thank you
for being here thank you for supporting
San Antonio Book Festival and the great
adventure of literature in San Antonio
we have an extraordinary treat today to
have Alexandra Zapruder with us who has
written an extraordinary book 26 seconds
a personal history of this approver film
it is a book that you really have to
read to to fully appreciate it I can
characterize it as a kind of a memoir of
the Zapruder film but it's in some
respects even deeper than that it's a
memoir of the extraordinary experience
burden destiny of a family a family that
has its own extraordinary story as as
essentially refugees of Jewish pogroms
in the Ukraine who find their way
ultimately to Dallas Texas and
Alexandra's grandfather was Abraham
Zapruder the the dressmaker who had the
extraordinary occasion to find himself
in that position on that day to capture
these 26 seconds of a faithful witness
of history and how many of you have seen
the Zapruder film see it's extraordinary
how many I mean how many people have
seen going with the wind
that's right up there it's right up
there in entering the annals new
question of America and in our
relationship our complex relationship to
media that that this this document this
artifact of our history is
simultaneously an artifact of media and
in some respects as as one colleague of
mine was described it was the the
initiation America had into reality TV
into reality media so it has an
extraordinary complex phenomenological
profile this this piece of film of home
movie of celluloid shot on one day in
one place in Dallas Texas and Alexandra
has done an extraordinary job of weaving
together the story of her family and the
incredible impact that this event had on
their lives and in fact also the best
discussion our scene and I'm a bit of a
cultist about the Zapruder film I have
to confess that you know I've dealt
deeply into the literature and the lore
around it but Alexandra has synthesized
it for us in a way that I think you will
find moving and confounding and
illuminating all at once because it's
just such a profound place so
Alexandra's career as a writers is quite
extraordinary and and she was
instrumental in some of the early
development of the Holocaust Memorial
Museum speaks to the very profound motif
in her family's story of the
relationship to Judaism as well an
extraordinary part of the testimonial in
this book she's a graduate of Smith
College and she served as the museum's
exhibition director for young visitors
she did a book called remember the
children Daniel's story that deals with
some of those experiences that the
museum captures and she earned her
master's degree at Harvard in 1995 in
education
her first book was salvaged pages young
writers Diaries of the Holocaust and it
was published by Yale Press and when the
National Jewish Book Awards so Alexandra
is a great writer of significant
achievement and there was a destiny to
come to this story undoubtedly as a
writer but I just want introduce
Alexandra first thank you for that
lovely introduction I'm glad it's being
recorded because I'm gonna listen to it
over and over and over again you know
it's interesting that you say that or
asked me sort of it was there a destiny
I think about this a lot with this book
because in a way this was a very
unlikely thing actually for me to decide
to do to write this book we I grew up in
a family in which and I wrote about this
some length and the introduction to the
book in which we really very very rarely
talked about the Zapruder film it was
really something that we all knew we
knew because we have this odd name and
people would you know ask about it but
it was not something that my parents
like to talk about at all my father in
particular my grandfather died when I
was an infant which was very very sad
for my father and then my own father
died when rather young and so I now
understand what that felt like for him
and so the film was always off-center it
was not I wouldn't say that it was quite
taboo it wasn't forbidden but it was
really not a defining we were not
encouraged to think of it as a defining
aspect of our identities at all and I
came to this topic in the aftermath of
my father's death finding myself with
questions as people often do wanting to
pull together the threads of this story
and coming to it fresh in a way I mean I
unlike you and unlike a lot of the
people that I meet I never read anything
about the Zapruder film I had no idea
what frankly what a big deal
was really I mean it sounds ridiculous
but it's true and so when I began to
read about it and try to get some handle
on what it represented I was not only
completely stunned by the scope and and
significance of it but also I began to
see the ways in which the kind of public
understanding of the film was missing
our family's story and the impact of our
families relationship on the film and so
that is what sort of justified the work
I asked myself a lot of questions about
whether this was you know was this
historically meaningful was it
worthwhile did I really have something
to contribute other than just sort of
the claim to fame of having this last
name and I would not have done the book
had I come out but in the end I really
believed that there was something about
our family's story that was going to
fill in some really important missing
pieces how did you first come to know
the significance of it when did you
first have a sense of it how did that
take shape well I remember you know it's
funny I tried to think about this when I
was working on the book my only memory
as a child distinct memory about the
film is that I I had a I remember
looking at my grandfather's name in the
index of William Manchester's book death
of a president and so I must have known
somehow that he was in the book and
reading about him in the book and when I
think about it now I think you know I
must have known on some level not to ask
my parents about it but rather to kind
of go this alternate route and I also
remember feeling like many sort of like
any 10 or 11 year old girl probably
would just like I was so famous this was
like the greatest thing that ever
happened to me you know and this is
exactly what my parents were so afraid
of and now having an 11 year old
daughter and an 8 year old son I
understand they also have my last name
and I understand how important it is to
impress upon them that you know this was
a national tragedy it was a tragedy for
the Kennedy family it was a tragedy for
our grandfather and
thus their that is exactly what you
don't want to do is sort of brag about
it but I feel like I had to go through
that you know that sense of like our
family is famous in order to you know
come out the other side and I and then
and then I didn't think about the film
again for years and years and years
until after really until after my dad
died you know it's you discuss in the
book not just the uncanny fate of your
grandfather's place and that day and and
the fact that that he was a home movie
enthusiast and and for those of us who
are cultists we also know then he'd
forgotten the camera that day and they
had to go back and get the camera and
was actually you give us a backstory he
was urged to go get a camera he was not
going to go do it
so it would be possible to imagine a
parallel universe where these appreader
film doesn't exist of that event but you
mentioned you know the fact that you
were Zapruder 'he's you know rather than
smith's you know like the smith film
your grandfather could have could have
faded away into history right but the
fact that you were Zapruder 'he's if you
if you just noticed when i was texting
you earlier that if you just put capr
siri
puts a brooder in your text message so
you carried that identification with you
and what did that mean in terms of your
growing up was it was it something that
did did conspiracy cultists seek you out
certainly not when I was growing up you
know when I was growing up being a
Zapruder meant a lot of things and not
being a Washingtonian it meant being
from a liberal family and meant being
Jewish it meant being the children of my
you know incredibly interesting engaging
parents lots of social guy I mean it
meant we all have these identities that
are formed by what we grow up with and
then there are the identities that you
don't realise that you've inherited and
that is what the story of the superior
film is for me I didn't I didn't
understand for most of my life that when
I met someone they might come to the
meeting of me with a whole set of
assumptions or ideas or understanding
about this
past that I didn't know about nice maybe
expert she watched a thousand times and
never watched it I mean absolutely never
watched it until until deciding to work
on this book so again in some ways it
was a very strange gift for the work
because coming to it with no background
in a way coming to it completely clean
meant that I could mine my own memories
in a way and then layer in this
information that I was learning it
wasn't like I one of the things that I
often said about this work as I was
doing it was I didn't come to this book
with a story to tell I didn't come to it
saying I have this whole story that I
need to impart to you I came to the work
with questions and with suspicions and
with ideas and and the book is the
inquiry the book is the is those is the
attempt to sort of put together these
pieces and one of the things I think
that is the most most important thing
about the work is that I realized when I
began reading about the film sort of
with in with it in mind that I might
want to write something about it after
my father died I realized that no one
really talked about it as a home movie
and it's interesting that you brought
that up people talk about it as evidence
people talk about it as an artifact that
was ended up being worth a lot of money
people talk about it as a cultural
touchstone people look at it as you know
a lens through which so to speak a lens
through which you can look at media
ethics and changing Morrie's but for our
family and for my grandfather most of
all the home movie quality of it the
fact that he had been making home movies
for 35 years at that point and that or
30 years and that he it was his camera
and his point of view and it was his
responsibility shaped everything that
followed and I think not knowing that
and not sort of putting the whole movie
back at the center of the story mmm that
it just meant that there were so many
distortions in the way
the story was told and the other public
records yeah you um you mentioned
something that had never occurred to me
before to even wonder about but what
what else was on that's that real and
the fact the fact that that there's a
pruder film that we know was preceded by
ordinary backyard machine adorable
cousin David who lives in San Antonio
who was with my children at the zoo
right now is on the first frames of the
film because that's what my grandfather
did he was filming all the time just
like everybody else did and when you and
it's so interesting because if you ever
see the film with those frames it looks
totally different you then seeing it
without this because it's so easy to
sort of to see it and to think this
could be by a professional photographer
or an AP news man or anybody but when
you see those frames of you know the
little kids playing outside you realize
like this is this he was he was really
there as a person who loved President
Kennedy who loved this country who had
such of his personal experience was so
tied up in the fate of America and
America represented so much for him
about possibility and destiny and so for
him it the whole you see it all in a
very different way I think you know I
have a copy of of a real that I don't
know who did it you know in in the
milieu that I was traveling around with
with our fascination with his approver
film people had these objects and and
this was a real assembling home movies
all along the route oh yes you know yes
so it's it's a it's an assemblage of
home movies from the time that the
Kennedys arrived at the airport into
which the Zapruder film is one part you
know you only get to the Zapruder film
after you've already traversed the the
route that of the Kennedys through the
road so you get a sense of both of the
act of witness that that your
grandfather experienced the fact that he
continued to shoot during the shooting
that he didn't you know take the camera
away and watch what was happening yeah
he stayed on camera you know so cam
the room might appreciate the audacity
of that but I wonder whether that the
trauma which you described so powerfully
throughout the book that the trauma that
your your grandfather experienced in
that moment whether that was in part
transmitted to the family to your to
your father and and your other superior
uncles and yes definitely I mean so I
mean one of the things that I think it's
just so important to say about this and
again this goes to not so much the story
that is told it this is in the book but
this is the whole frame of the book
before you even get to the content of it
my my father had written I discovered
this in the course of the research for
this book I didn't know it before my
father wrote two letters to John F
Kennedy one when he was a senator and
one when he was president 1962 my father
just graduated from law school at
Harvard wrote to the president pleading
for a job roading a wrote a beautiful
letter such an idealistic letter by my
father who was 20 years younger than I
am now even more wanting to work for the
new frontier and wanting to be part of
john f kennedy's administration and then
got a job and he and my mother married
on October 31st 1963 and he they had
their honeymoon and then came to
Washington so he was two weeks into his
new job in the Justice Department
working for Bobby Kennedy when the
assassination happened and as I was
saying earlier too at lunch my aunt had
volunteered in the Kennedy campaign and
had sold poll-tax
in Dallas and she was at Love Field when
Jackie and John Kennedy arrived with her
friend my uncle was watching the
motorcade from the Praetorian building
on Main Street and my grandfather was at
Dealey Plaza
so they were I mean there kennedy 'no
side part of their i mean they were deep
kennedy people and then as i said again
at this lunch today my parents stayed up
all night in washington to walk by the
president's body lying in state at the
Capitol building
so the intimacy with which our family
along with millions of other people were
kind of whoa
even into this story again makes the
film so much more powerful and I think
that's where the I don't know if I
wouldn't say describe it as trauma for
myself but where there are
reverberations you know my father who
the disappointment of the assassination
the pain of it the sadness of it the
laws the sense of betrayal stayed with
him for his whole life
and then to be but for all of them for
my grandfather and then my father to
then be responsible for this object to
be the ones who had to decide who uses
it how under what circumstances for how
much money at what cost morally and
ethically what is the cost to society of
sharing it too widely what is the cost
to society of not sharing it widely
enough who should make that decision and
then all of that against the backdrop of
changing times what would the what were
those questions in the 60s versus the
70s and the 80s and the 90s I think that
the the burden of that would have been
difficult for anyone but but the irony
of it landing on the shoulders of the
very people who you know so loved this
president I think is sort of remarkable
I mean there's some many ironies that
run through your very literary telling
of this story you know the fact that
that your grandfather was a dressmaker
who essentially knocked off dresses
right what about your grandmother would
go get dresses from Neiman Marcus and
and then you put them on her chronic mr.
Zapruder had a shop and they would
basically make copies of those dresses
so but the fact that then the issue of
copies of the film would become that's a
great such a haunting in his life so so
the intimacy the extraordinary telling
these moments when you describe for
instance there's an extraordinary
description Alexander gives us of the
night of the assassination they're able
to essentially get the film processed
immediately
and mr. Zapruder brings the film home
and they watched the movie in the family
dining room yeah just you know as a
profound moment in American history
being lived in that intimate space when
I think that moment I began the book
with that as a sort of prologue because
I think that sort of encapsulates the
whole home movie quality of it I mean he
came home after this traumatic terrible
day and did the same thing that he had
done with the home movies for 30 years
before that he showed it in my father's
room which was the den and my
grandmother and my uncle were there and
they watched it and my aunt refused to
watch it because she was hysterical and
she was in the living room crying
instead and you know this sort of the
twisted nature you know this is
something so familiar and it is such a
familiar pattern and thing that the
family would do together but then it has
this you know this cast to it that is so
different and and not knowing in that
moment having no way of knowing what
this was going to become and having a
sense perhaps of the broad outlines of
the problems that we're going to attend
the film but not really being able to
even conceive of the role that it would
go on to play in American life I mean
that was the great surprise and you've
done such an amazing job also I mean
there's the the the intimate literary
voice that runs through this book and
then there's an extraordinary chronicle
of the forensics around the film and as
a journalist you undertook that I think
you know with with some peril I mean so
many people are written about it you've
assembled it's such an interesting way
so how did how did that challenge how
did you decide to undertake that
challenge to really map out the the
generations of copies and additions and
replications and I may never recover
from that that decision actually you
know it's interesting what I wanted to
do with this book was to tell the whole
history of the life of the film meaning
both the fit those sort of interrelated
families
story the public and private story but
also the life of the film as a cultural
touchstone as an artifact its role in
the media its role as a as a valuable
object and there's no way to do that
without also tackling its use as a piece
of evidence in the assassination debates
and so I taught myself that history I
mean I did that is not a history that I
knew and I my main goal was to stay
always focused on the film
what role did the film play in the
Warren Commission what role did the film
play in the House Select Committee on
assassinations not to get off into the
autopsy photos and the ballistics and
the forensics but always to look at how
was the film used and one of the things
that was so fascinating for me that I I
learned in the course of doing this of
course was that and I knew this on some
level but I don't think I quite
understood it to this degree the film
complicates everything the existence of
the film which should in theory clarify
everything complicates everything and
everyone who sees the film sees
something different depending on what
you're looking for and what you already
believe and there is no consensus on
what happened to the president even
though there is this extraordinary
visual record and so there's an inherent
conflict in the existence of the film
itself which I think then becomes a kind
of it sort of almost is like a like a
predictor for the future that we now
live in a time and this has evolved over
time but we now live in a time when you
know simple pieces of information facts
or documents or photographs or are not
necessarily enough to prove us that one
thing or another happened and so it's
sort of this very it's interesting how
it started to go in this direction and
and ended up you know now where we are
well I was wondering also just and just
getting ready to close here so so
Alexander can read us a little bit and
then we'll
QA so of some time for your questions
I'm interested wrote memoirs that cause
perturbations in my family I'm wondering
how the larger Zapruder family has
received this book I was struck by the
fact that your one brother is a poet
Matthew Zapruder I'd seen the name he
yet it's the poetry section for the New
York Times Magazine and your twin
brother is an artist yes they dealt with
this material in their work and then
just how is that okay they have known in
the family yes they have not dealt with
this work in their this topic in their
work and they and they probably wouldn't
I would say there were mixed reactions
in the family I mean it's hard for me to
overstate just how disruptive this was
as a proposed project I mean I think
some and the families sort of always
feared that this day would come
you know that somebody would finally
decide to write up like obviously write
a book about this appreader film but I
think there was resistance because there
is a deep there are a deep set of very
difficult moral and ethical questions
that are at the heart of this book can
you profit financially from a record
like this without making a fundamental
moral compromise what are the mitigating
factors how do how did we as a family
grapple with these questions privately
and publicly and that was a good enough
reason for me not to want to write this
book for a long time because I thought I
know I adored my father and he died and
I didn't know my grandfather and I wish
I had and what if I stumble on something
that I don't want to write about so I
think everybody had a little bit of that
and everybody had a little bit of we're
a private family we've always adhered to
this kind of discretion out of respect
for the Kennedy family so it really was
kind of upsetting not necessarily in a
negative sense but literally upsetting
but I will say that my aunt who was the
daughter of my grandfather my was very
much behind it from the beginning and I
would not have been able to do it
without her because I interviewed her
and she just cut every time I went to
her house she'd hand me another stack of
things you know and I would say like
what were you doing with me why are
these things still here I'm trying to
collect everything you know and my
brothers for sure were very supportive
because I think you know they're artists
and they felt like if this if these are
your questions you know if this is your
work and this is what you need to do
then this is then we want you to do it
and now that it's out everybody is fine
but but it was it was it was hard it was
very hard and it took me a long time to
kind of embrace the personal nature of
it and find my own voice in it that was
definitely a an involved process when I
had family members raised issues I would
tell them write your own book yeah right
Ruth well would you read I'll read one
just short part from the epilogue
because I think it's a good way to end
and the epilogue in the epilogue I sort
of try my best to bring together the
personal legacy of the film for our
family and sort of deal a little bit
with some of the unanswered questions
from my childhood and then the public
one pulling together all of these
different threads that I've followed
through the book itself so this is this
is the very last few pages of the book
what is the public legacy of the
Zapruder film what is the compelling
lore that makes the assassination
researchers the film art and cultural
historians the writers and journalists
the academics and studi students and
hobbyists and kennedy buffs return to it
as a touchstone time and again I have
come to think that it is because the
Zapruder film is in every way a
conundrum
it contains its own irreconcilable
contradictions it is visual evidence
that refuses to solve the mystery of who
murdered the president why and how it is
a single strip of film in which we all
see different things
it shows the entire course of history
changing under the influence of a single
bullet it is quite possibly the most
important historical film ever made and
yet it is an amateur home movie it is
six feet of eight millimeter film on a
plastic reel that turned out to be worth
16 million dollars it is the most
private and the most public of records
it is gruesome and terrible but we
cannot stop looking at it but more than
that the deepest most compelling
conundrum of the film is an existential
one it lies in the arc of the film
itself the fall from grace the
unforgiving inevitability of it it is a
sunny day a handsome husband and his
beautiful wife are riding down the
street smiling and waving with their
lives stretched out before them and
within less than half a minute his head
explodes and he is dead and she is
covered in his brains and blood trying
to recover his skull from the trunk of
the limousine he is alive and then he is
dead she is a wife and then she is a
widow she is grace itself and then she
has sprawled across the back of the car
how can it be that our protections and
illusions can be stripped from us so
quickly most of us are able to live our
days exactly because we are not
confronted with this vulnerability the
inexplicable capriciousness of fate the
permanence of death and yet there is the
Zapruder film it exists and we cannot
turn away even though we fear it and we
avert our eyes and we wish desperately
that it would end differently every time
maybe it is the same impulse that causes
us to watch the Challenger explode in
the bright blue Florida sky or the Twin
Towers crashed down into lower Manhattan
on a crisp fall morning it is because we
resist the knowledge that hope sometimes
turns to despair in an instant and that
tragedy comes out of nowhere on a
beautiful day and paradoxically because
sometimes we need to confront that very
truth simply to see the thing that we
feel cannot happen
in order to touch for a moment the very
limits of what we know about life and to
remind ourselves of the fragility of it
all questions otherwise I will continue
to ask on but I know everybody must have
questions yes oh yeah we I need to get
you on the mic so we yeah yeah thank you
yeah hello
can you please touch on the connection
to Life magazine at that time sure the
question is about Life magazine and the
connection with Life magazine Richard
Stolley who was a reporter a journalist
with Life magazine purchased on behalf
of life the still rights to the film the
day after the assassination and then the
moving footage rights a few days later
and Life magazine owned the film for 12
years after the assassination the reason
my grandfather sold the film to life
first of all he knew that he couldn't
keep it he was being hounded by
reporters instantly and and aggressively
so I think he felt a need to to do you
know get it out of his own hands but he
trusted Richard Stolley and Richard
Stolley really on behalf of life really
promised to treat the film with dignity
and with restraint which was extremely
important to my grandfather I mean his
biggest fear was that it was going to be
exploited and sensationalized and that
it was going to be all over the
newspapers and the television and and
particularly that Jackie Kennedy would
see it so
Life magazine then had it for 12 years
and one of the amazing things that
happened for me when I decided to do
this work was that I went back to Life
magazine and I asked if I could see the
the archives and they just hand it over
the entire written record of the life of
the film at life which were documents
that had never been made public with
anyone so there are all these letters
and
is that really so the whole middle part
of the book really goes through what was
happening inside Life magazine how they
handled the film the various
controversies and of course
Life magazine held the film very tightly
and never showed it as a film to the
American people but during those years
there was the rise of bootleg copies
through various sources and of course
the rise of the conspiracy theories
partly fed by the fact that people
couldn't see the film so an unintended
consequence and then this relationship
between life and the film ended in 1975
when they returned the film to our
family for a dollar and there is a story
behind that which is told in the book
but essentially they were under
tremendous pressure from the public from
other news outlets and others to make it
available and they they couldn't do that
and and treat it tastefully and that was
their conflict so they decided to get
rid of it and they were prepared to
donate it to the National Archives but
my grandmother intervened and I will
leave it at that it's a story that is
told in the book I think many of us
remember the first scene first the still
images in life and and then later the
first moving images on the head although
ravenna show right what was a good night
yeah yeah
good night America so that was so a
bootleg copy of the film was shown to
the American public for the first time
in 1975 April 1975 just as these
negotiations were going on and that was
more or less the final straw for Life
magazine because part of their their
sort of terms of their contract were
that they had to defend the copyright to
the film and prevent it from being used
in ways that were not sanctioned and
here it was on Geraldo was out it was
over there was nothing to be done about
it and so at that point they just were
ready to be rid of it and I can't say
that I blame them another question
somebody else
you know one of the please gather your
question and head to that mic can you
talk a little bit about how maybe your
grandfather's immigrant experience
played a role in his reaction to what
happened yes thank you
you know my grandfather came to this
country in 1920 as a 15 year old boy
having endured horrendous persecution
and suffering as a as a Jew in Imperial
Russia he had three kid two sisters and
a brother the brother was either killed
or died it's not exactly clear what
happened to him
and they came here in 1920 my
grandfather went to night school to
learn English and then like almost all
the other Jews in his situation went
into the needle trades and and became a
dressmaker and then he and my
grandmother went to Dallas in 1941 and
by the time the assassination happened
he was running a successful dress
manufacturing business but I think his
whole life was shaped by these traumatic
early years and the sense that he didn't
have an education and he was somewhat
insecure as a result of that but I think
in particular when the in the aftermath
of the assassination his his values and
Jewish values in particular I think
largely shaped his sense of what was and
was not appropriate and decent to do
with the film which were immediately in
conflict with American norms already
even in 1963 to say nothing of today
and I think he was very much afraid that
profiting from the film selling it to
Life magazine both would be perceived in
a negative light and that would would
potentially spark anti-semitic reactions
but more than that that it actually was
wrong not just that it might seem like
it was wrong but it might actually be
wrong and so he was really I think
he was torn by that and I think his his
whole perspective and his decision to
sell to Life magazine and then to give
away he gave away $25,000 to the widow
of the police officer who was shot by
Oswald again his way of sort of the
taking of the money kind of reflected
his own financial insecurity and poverty
and fear and the sense that it was
important to sort of take this windfall
even though the taking of it was
complicated but also to give away a
portion of the money in order to assuage
his own complicated sense of guilt and
responsibility for it and that those
basic and and to define the terms of the
deal with Life magazine to try to
mitigate the damage that the film would
cause and I think those basic elements
remained a hundred percent current for
my father when he inherited a much much
more complicated set of decisions in
1975 and through the 70s and 80s and 90s
when he was dealing with the film he I
think always went back to my
grandfather's values as a sort of
guideposts for figuring out how to deal
with the phone even though times had
changed and things were much more
complicated the question yes you
probably don't address this in your book
and it may be far removed from the story
there but to me I can remember in 1963
and it seemed to me our family didn't
have one but a lot of people had movie
cameras did you spend a lot of time
thinking about and there were a lot of
people along that route right there did
you think about why was it just your
grandfather who happened to get the only
film we know of I find that incredible
yeah there were there were 21 other
photographers along the parade route the
end of the parade route and those films
are incredibly valuable and important I
think the thing
about my grandfather's film that is
different is that it it encapsulates the
whole story and it is so clear and it's
and it has this there's an arc to it
which is sort of what I alluded to in
the epilogue that you know the whole
story not only of the Kennedys and their
fall from grace and this tragic event
but the whole story of human life and
what we strive for and what our fate is
it's all there
and it's and that makes it different
from other things and I also think there
are those who have said and I think that
this is true the composition of it I
mean if you just look at this you know
image this bright green grass and the
pink of the first lady's suit and the
black of the limousine there's something
visually that you know now of course we
have this nostalgic relationship to it
but even at the time I think it was
there's really no accounting for it it's
just that is the way that it looked but
it it grabbed people and it never let go
have the other films of Abraham Zapruder
been preserved there yes they have been
preserved so they have they my aunt my
aunt yeah yeah well right step up we
have about three more minutes so we can
do part question
have you actually held the object the
original film no the original film is in
the National Archives and the film was
taken from our family and then in the
1990s by the federal government
precipitating a long struggle to
determine ownership and value and in
fact it's funny because I asked I wrote
to the National Archives after while I
was working on the book to ask if I
could see the original film and there
was a lot of back and forth and hemming
and hawing and then they said no and I
thought well it's really not ours
anymore is it that's it the second part
of the question is this is just touching
the the rabbit-hole is this all can get
into there was a lot of discussion about
two frames of the film being flipped in
the film
the actual artifact being manipulated
yeah just discussed that I did I did get
into the questions of the alteration of
the film which is there's a whole theory
that that rose up sort of more in the
1990s about altering the film the two
frames that you're referring to I
believe are the way that the film was
presented in the Warren Commission
exhibits frames three I believe it was
three thirteen and three fourteen were
shown frame three thirteen is the
critical frame that shows the head wound
to the president they were printed in
reverse order which was either just the
most unbelievably dunderheaded thing
that somebody did or it was something
worse than that but it doesn't really I
mean so it was very dubious that that
happened and there were also frames that
were damaged by the Life magazine people
in the weekend of the assassination when
they were rushing to go to print with
the first issue of images of the film
and six frames were damaged and spliced
out but life made the mistake of not
coming public with that until much later
which led to an enormous amount of
speculation that that the film had been
altered and then there's a larger
alteration theory which I won't get into
now because of the time but that I went
into and a great length in the book
possibly not very nicely was a way of
ending this great visit with Alexander I
just wanted to read the last two
sentence as a way of also commending the
book to you and Alexander's gonna be
signing just after our chat here the
Supriya film is not a reality that we
can live with every minute of every day
but it holds and it's terrible 26
seconds a painful fundamental human
truth that will never grow old and that
every generation must grapple with for
itself
[Applause]
[Music]
and the final author you'll hear from
the San Antonio Book Festival is Lydia
pine she discusses the lesser-known
fossil discoveries that have changed our
understanding of evolution
good afternoon we're gonna go ahead and
get started we'd like to welcome you to
the skeletons in the closet session my
name is Jennifer Matthews I'm a
professor of anthropology at Trinity
University here in San Antonio and this
is my colleague Lydia pine and we want
to first of all say thank you for coming
to the session and we want to thank the
San Antonio Public Library as well as
the Southwest school of arts and crafts
for opening up their facilities for this
great event today and we are also
supposed to encourage everybody to
please post any of your photos your
tweets and things please put those up on
social media and use the hashtag si
Bookfest or si at si Book Festival for
Twitter so please put those out there
out into the